ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้า
สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดี
ค่ะครูฟ้าคะวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วัน
ศุกร์ค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 15
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนเมษายน
ปีพตอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
ปีคศอะไรคะมีคศ 2  022 ค่ะเมื่อวานนี้วัน
อะไรคะเมื่อวานนี้วันพฤหัสบดีวันที่เท่า
ไหร่คะวันที่ 14 เดือนเดือนเมษายน
อาตีผชปีพ.ศ
ปีคศปีค.ศ
2022 ค่ะ
หมีวันอะไรคะพรุ่งนี้วันเสาร์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 16 เดือนเดือน
เมษายน
ปีพตตปีพต 2  5  6 ห้าปีค.ศต.ค.ปีคศ 2
022 ค่ะแล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูฟ้าตอน
นี้เวลา
13:00 น 13:00 นนี้
บ่ายโมงกี่นาทีคะ
13:00 น 25 นาทีน่ะค่ะบ่ายโมง 25 นาที
น้องก็เป็นเวลากลางวันนะคะร้อนอาหาร
วันนี้นะคะคลุมป่าร้อนใช้ค่ะครูหญิงเนี่ย
มีเกมมาเล่นกับครูฟ้าเป็นเกมที่เช็คว่า
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยไอคิวดีไหม
ไม่อยากรู้นะคะนี่ผู้หญิงจะมีคำถามนะคะ
ครูฟ้า
ถามครูฟ้า
ถึงมี noise ค่ะถามว่าถามยาว
ยาวที่สุดยาวที่สุดก็คืออันดับที่ 1 จะ
ไหมคะเวลายาวเนี่ยประเทศไทยเราคิดเป็น
อะไรอ่ะกิโลเมตรเซนติเมตรกิโลกรัม you
Meet แต่ว่ายาวก็จะเป็นกิโลเมตร
ถ้าเราก็จะเป็นยาอันนี้จะมีสองสามแต่เรา
จะเอาที่ 1 ก็คือยาวที่สุดในประเทศไทย
ผู้หญิงสถามแล้วมันก็จะมี
ABC  ei ครูฟาเรือเราไม่ต้องกลัว
ผู้หญิง 3
ยาวทิศในประเทศไทยนะคะนักเรียน
รู้นั่นก็ตอบได้นะตอบใส่ถึงวันนั้นบอกผู้
หญิงทิ้งคอมเม้นต์ได้นะคะ
คนไทยนะอ่ะข้อที่ 1 ค่ะครูฟ้าข้อที่ 1
เนี่ยครูหญิงจะถามเกี่ยวกับแม่น้ำ
สวยแม่น้ำ
แม่นางน้ำครูฟ้ารู้จักแม่น้ำอะไรบ้างใน
ไม่ใช่ในประเทศไทยก็ได้นะในโลกพี่น้อง
อเมริกาเกาหลีญี่ปุ่นเยอรมันในโลกแม่น้ำ
โขง
มีใกล้ๆประเทศไทยแม่น้ำโขง her แม่น้ำมี
40 ปีใช่มั้ยใช่ไหมคะแม่น้ำเทมส์
แม่น้ำอะไรอีกครูฟ้าครูฟ้ารู้ไหมว่าในโลก
นะคะในโลกนะต้อย
ปี้อันนี้คือโลกใช่ไหมคะ
ว่าคุณโอเคโจผู้หญิง
ในรู้
ลูกผู้หญิงหายนะคะขอโทษด้วยค่ะในโลกค่ะ
นักเรียนใช่ดูของเรานะฮะค่ะในโลก
เข้าแก่คิดว่ามาแล้วมั้งในโลกนะมีอเมริกา
มีโป้เกาหลีมีญี่ปุ่นนะคะโลกเนาะโลกของ
เราหนูโลกมันอันนี้คือโลกน่ะใช่ค่ะครูฟ้า
รู้ไหมว่าในโลกเนี่ยในโลกที่ครูฟ้าวาด
เนี่ยแม่น้ำอะไรที่ยาวอ่าๆเอาที่สุดในโลก
ระยะยาวที่ 1 เลยยาวที่ 1 เป็นแชมเปี้ยน
ป่ะรู้ไหม
แม่น้ำอะไรอ่ะแม่น้ำไนล์นะคนไทยพูดแม่น้ำ
ไนล์นะคะหนูว่าแต่อันนี้อ่อนี้ยังไม่ใช่
คำถามใช่ไหมคะไม่ใช่เขาถามว่าใช้คำถามใน
โลกเนี่ยไม่ใช่คำถามค่ะ
แต่กูฟ้ารู้ใช่ไหมแม่น้ำตายใช่ไหมคะอย่า
ฟ้าวที่สุดในโลก
อยู่สุภารู้ไหมยาวเท่าไหร่
เห้ย 3,000
ก็
ไม่รู้นั่งฟังกว่าค่ะมากกว่าอัน
550 กิโลเมตรนะที่เอาไข่ยาวนะคะยาวใช่
ไหมสัตว์อยู่ในแอฟริกาน้อยจากที่นี่แล้ว
ก็สตาร์ทแล้วก็ไปไปๆๆเนี่ยยาวเนาะอันนี้
ไม่ใช่คำถามคำถามแล้วถ้าประเทศไทย
ประเทศไทยนะคะอ่ะผู้หญิงมีรูปประเทศไทย
คิดว่าจะแชร์ได้นะนี่ค่ะอันนี้คือประเทศ
ไทยใช่ไหมประเทศไทยนะคะนี่นะคะที่มีสี
เนี่ยในประเทศไทยแม่น้ําอะไรยาวที่สุดยาว
ที่สุดในประเทศไทยนะ 1
อีก
หนึ่งมหาเถเรละกัน a
แม่น้ำชีน้องแม่น้ำชีแหละอยู่ที่นี่ค่ะ
ภาคอีสานนักแม่น้ำซี
นะแม่น้ำมูลแม่น้ำมูลก็อยู่ภาคอีสาน
เหมือนกันนะอยู่ตรงนี้อันนี้ไหมหามูล
อันนึงนะคะเหลือจะบอกแล้วปูปลาอาจจะรู้
ใช่ไหมหาแม่น้ำชีแหละอยู่ประมาณตรงนี้นะ
คะแม่น้ำชีแล้วก็ C แม่น้ำเจ้าพระยาแม่
น้ำเจ้าพระยาอยู่ที่นี่นะคะสตาร์ทที่นี่
ABC แม่น้ำอะไรน้องแม่น้ำอะไร
แม่น้ำที่ยาวที่สุดในประเทศไทยไปเนี่ยแม่
น้ำนะคะยาวที่สุดในประเทศไทยแม่น้ำอะไร
แม่น้ำชีแม่น้ำมูลคุณแม่น้ำเจ้าพระยา
แม่น้ำ
เจ้าพระยาค่ะคิดค่ะแม่น้ำค่ะแม่น้ำชี
ถูกค่ะ
A
แม่น้ำชีนะคะยาวที่สุดในประเทศไทยมีกี่
กิโลเมตรคะผู้หญิงขอดูได้ไหมคะได้ค่ะ
กิโลเมตรค่ะแม่น้ำชีเนาะยาวมากๆนะคะเพราะ
ว่าแบบอ่าถ้าสมมตินักเรียนดูแผนที่ประเทศ
ไทย
เนาะแม่น้ำชีเนี่ยมันก็มาจากแม่น้ำโขงนะ
คะมันก็ Like  Like  Like ๆอย่าอย่ายาวมา
ม้าขายาวที่สุดในประเทศไทย
เก่งมากค่ะคำถามข้อที่สองครูหญิงสถาม
เกี่ยวกับในรูปนี้ค่ะครูฟ้าอะไรคะถนน
ถนนใจไหมคะถนนเนี่ยก็ก็อย่าอย่างเอา
เหมือนกัน
ถนนที่ยาวที่สุดในประเทศไทย
อย่างถนนที่
ยาวที่สุดในโลก
ในโลกนี้ครูฟ้ารู้ไหม
อยู่ที่ไหนเดี๋ยวผิงน่าจะรูปโลกได้แล้ว
อ่ะมาแล้วลูกโลกเห็นใช่ไหมคะค่ะ
ครูฟ้ารู้ไหมว่าถนนณถนนค่ะอันนี้คือถนนมี
รถเนาะอ่าถนนที่ยาวที่สุดในโลกเนี่ยชื่อ
อะไรเดี๋ยวมันยากนะคะแต่ผู้ฟ้ารู้หรือว่า
อยู่ที่ไหนแค่หน้าได้อเมริกาบราซิล
รัสเซีย
จีน of  Australia
ป่ะรู้ไหม
ถนนที่ยาวที่สุดในโลก
ว่าจะไม่ได้อ่ะ
กูก็เคยรู้ใช่ไหมได้หากว่าเคยเล่นเกมฮะ
อันยุ
น้องเรียน
อยู่ที่อเมริกาค่ะ
ไออ่ะ
จากอลาสก้าหรอจากอลาสก้ามาแคนาดามา
อเมริกามาเม็กซิโกมามาๆ
นะคะชาวมากๆครูฟ้ารู้ไหมว่ายาวเท่าไหร่
ยาวเท่าไหร่คะผู้หญิง
ยาววิ่งดูก่อนนะคะจำไม่ได้นะคะประมาณ
เมื่อสองหมื่น
9800 ไม้นะว่าอเมริกาเนี่ยไม่ใช้กม.เนาะ
มาย
สายตัดกลับมาที่ประเทศไทยนะคะประเทศไทย
เล่นประเทศไทยถนนที่
ยาวที่สุดในประเทศไทยเนี่ยถนนอะไรครูฟ้า
[เพลง]
HA นะฮะ a ถนนสุขุมวิทนะสุขุมวิทก็คือ
กรุงเทพฯแล้วก็ไปไปๆภาคตะวันออกแล้วก็ถึง
นี่นะคะสุขุมวิท a นะมี
ดีนะคะบีสีเขียวแล้วกันเนาะบีถนนเพชรเกษม
ถนนเพชรเกษมก็กรุงเทพฯแล้วก็ไปต่อไปไปภาค
ใต้นะคะถึงสงขลาถนนเพชรเกษมที่ซีเอาสี
อะไรดีสีชมพู
ซีถนนพหลโยธินและถนนพหลโยธินก็กรุงเทพฯ
แล้วก็ขึ้นขึ้นขึ้นขึ้นขึ้นไปถึงเชียงราย
ค่ะ
ครูฟ้าคิดว่าถนนอะไร
ยาวที่สุดในประเทศไทย
ABC
ถนนสุขุมวิท
ค่ะ
ป้าโอเคไหมครูหญิงว่าเส้นครูฟ้าดูก็เข้า
ใจว่าสั้นที่สุดว่ากูฟ้าเป็นทีมถนน
สุขุมวิทนักเรียนมฟ้าถึงแม้สุขุมวิทมันจะ
เป็นบ้านของเราแต่มาเล่นเกมส์ค่ะ
ถนนอะไรคะครูบาตอบคุณเพชรเกษมน่ะกูป่าว
บอกว่าสินะสิถนนเพชรเกษมถูกค่ะ
เก่งมากเก่งดี
แล้วครูฟ้ายากรู้ไหมถนนเพชรเกษมอ่ะยาว
เท่าไหร่เลยถนนเพชรเกษมยาวกี่กิโลเมตรคะ
ครีม
ยาวหรอ
1,000
270  14
กิโลเมตรนะคะ
นักเรียนอาจจะดูแล้วรู้สึก
ถนน
พหลโยธินก็ยาวแต่สั้นกว่านะเพราะว่าจาก
กรุงเทพแล้วก็ลงลดลงภาคใต้เนี่ยมันดับมัน
เลี้ยวเลี้ยวเลี้ยวเลี้ยวมันก็เลยยาวนะคะ
กูพระเก่งมากนะคะอ่ะก็ยังมีเวลาเนาะข้อ
ต่อไปนะคะแม่น้ำไปแล้วนะถนนไปแล้วนะคะแต่
แม่น้ำเนี่ยแม่น้ำเนี่ยมันยาวใช่ไหมมัน
ยาวแต่มันไม่ได้ยาวอย่างเดียวนะมันกว้าง
ใช่ไหมคะมันกว้างถ้ามึงฟ้าบ้านครูฟ้าอยู่
ตรงนี้อันนี้บ้านครูหญิงใช่ไหมคะครูฟ้า
อยากจะมาหาครูหญิงเนี่ยผู้ฟ้าต้องว่ายน้ำ
มาได้ไหมไม่ได้ไม่ได้ใช่ไหมคะแม่น้ำเนี่ย
เขาก็เลยมี
สะพานมีราคะสะพาน
ในรูปเนี้ยครูฟ้าคือสะพานที่
อ๊ะป่าวเอาที่สุดในโลก
Who ยาวมากครูบาคิดว่าอยู่ที่ไหนรัสเซีย
จ้าไม่ใช่รัสเซีย
7  9 ไม่ใช่อังกฤษอ่ะ
และแคนาดา
เอเชียเอเชีย
อินเดีย
ไม่ใช่ไม่ได้ตอบหรือ
ตีนกูลืมตีนหรือยังไงล่ะแม่มากนะคะจ่าย
ใส่ค่ะประเทศจีนค่ะเป็นสะพานหรอสะพานที่
ครูหญิงให้ดูนะคะสะพานอันนี้นะเป็นสะพาน
ที่ยาวที่สุดในโลกตอนนี้นะที่กูหญิงถาม
ฟ้าเนี่ยสะพานนี้นะคะชื่ออะไรไม่เป็นไรจำ
ไม่ได้นะคะแต่เขาบอกว่ายาว
กูยาวอยู่นะสำหรับสะพานเนาะ
กิโลเมตรนะคะเนี่ยว่าจะที่นี่แล้วก็มาถึง
ที่นี่ยาวนะสำหรับสะพานเนี่ยถ้าเป็น
กิโลเมตรอ่ะและกะอันนี้ในโลกนะคะแต่ถ้า
ประเทศไทยนะคะประเทศไทยนี่นะคะประเทศไทย
สะพานอะไร
ยาวที่สุดในประเทศไทย
ครูฟ้าบอกว่าโอ้โหครูฟ้าจะรู้ไหมอ่ะไม่
เป็นไรนะครูฟ้าข้อที่สั่งเนี่ยครูหญิง
เนี่ยมีรูปสะพานให้ดู
มาเลยค่ะอันนี้สัมพันธ์จีนใช่ไหมไม่ใช่
ประเทศไทยไม่เอานะเขาไม่เอานะคะอ่ะ
อันนี้คือ a  a นะคะ a ตรงนี้ก็คือแม่น้ำ
เศร้าพระยานะคะนักเรียนแม่น้ำทรัพย์พระยา
เอมเนี่ยนะคะสอบพรานพระราม 8 นะคะสะพาน
พระราม 8 กับเป็นสะพานของนี่คือในหลวง
ในหลวงนะคะในหลวงที่ 8 เนาะสะพานพระราม 8
นะคะเอ
บีนะคะบีดี
เนี่ยสะพานอันนี้นะคะชื่อ
สะพานติณสูลานนท์
สวัสดการดีหน่อยนะไม่เป็นไรนะคะอันนี้นะ
แม่นะอันนี้ไม่ใช่แม่น้ำนะคะนี่เป็นทะเล
สาบนี้เป็นเล็กนะคะเล็กนะคะไม่ใช่แม่น้ำ
แล้วก็ดิ DB ใช่ไหมพิมพ์พูดดีใช่ไหมให้ฮะ
แล้วก็ซื้อ cc นะคะ senior สะพานภูมิพล
แล้วเงินเราไม่เอาพานภูมิพลเนี่ย
เป็นชื่อของในหลวงที่เท่าไหร่คะครูฟ้า
ในหลวงที่ 9 ค่ะที่ 9 นะคะนี่นะคะสะพาน
สบายๆ
สะพานภูมิพล
นี้นะคะครูฟ้าคิดว่าสะพานไหน
ยายาวที่สุดในประเทศไทย A  B  C หรือ C  C
นี้ 4 ใช่ไหมคะสะพานภูมิพล B สะพาน
ติณสูลานนท์
a สะพานพระราม 8
ออกอะไรนี้นะคะคุณฟ้าตอบ
จุดๆจุดสะพาน
ติณสูลานนท์ค่ะครูฟ้าบอกว่าบีสะพาน
ติณสูลานนท์
ผู้หญิงบอกให้ก็ได้ค่ะว่า
สะพานพระราม 8 เนี่ยไม่ใช่นะคะไม่ใช่
สะพานที่ยาวที่สุดในประเทศไทยนะคะ
บีมีกับ 4 มหาก็จะเป็นไงค่ะเหลือพอดีกับ
สี
ผิดอาญาผู้หญิง
ตามนะเหลือสะพานติณสูลานนท์กับสะพาน
ภูมิพล
ผู้ฟ้าเปลี่ยนใจไหม
ไม่มีความมั่นใจใช่ไหมคะว่าเป็นสะพาน
ตินลสูลานนท์
โหหูฟ้า
ผู้หญิงวันเดาค่ะค่ะ
สะพานติณสูลานนท์นะคะยาว 2,000 บาท
600 เท่าไหร่คะ 4  10 เมตรนะคะนักเรียน
Best นะไม่ใช่
เมตรน้ำได้ค่ะแต่ว่าถ้าเป็นสะพานภูมิพล
สะพานภูมิพลเขามี 1 กับ 2 นะมีภูมิพล 1
กับที่ 2 นะคะเรื่องเนี้ย
ประมาณ 1,000
1,000 มั้ง 1000 เมตรนะคะประมาณนะอาจจะ
ไม่ถึงนะคะจะ
อาจจะประมาณคิดว่า 900 เมตรนะคะ
ประมาณ 900 เมตรนะครับประมาณนะประมาณถึง
จำไม่ได้นะคะแต่นักเรียนดูแล้วถูกหูยาว
มากๆใช่ไหมคะอันนี้ก็เป็นสะพานหนอที่ยาว
ที่สุดในประเทศไทยนะคะวันนี้เราก็มีคำถาม
เกี่ยวกับยาวที่สุดในประเทศไปนะคะน้องไม่
แลกเรียนตอบถูกไหมทำไมต้องอันนี้หมดงาน
แล้วนะคะเจอกันวีดีโอหน้านะคะสวัสดีค่ะ
หน้า
[เพลง]